I'd like to give a congratulations to Mr
Ray EPS on avoiding jail time despite
privately saying he orchestrated January
6 and being seen on camera numerous
times advocating people enter the
building which is of course inciting an
Insurrection by Democrat standards and
then of course I'd like to give an
honorable mention to Enrique tario for
beating the record of Ray apps by
getting 20 plus years in prison despite
not even being in DC so of course the
internet is right with individuals
accusing Ray EPS of being a Fed because
it makes quite no sense that of all the
people that have been charged some 1700
many of them are rece have received jail
time and some of them did literally
nothing like walking around Ray EPS
actually was at the front line where
they breached the barricade he was
telling people to enter the capital
premeditated and he admitted on camera
he knew that doing so was a crime he
would be arrested for he gets no jail
time no travel restrictions a $500 fine
$100 community service oh boy Donald
Trump was in court today his legal team
was arguing he's immune unless impeached
and convicted and what's really got all
the Democrats quite angry is that his
legal team argued and I would say
correctly that a president could
assassinate a political rival and they
cannot be criminally charged unless they
are impeached and convicted which makes
absolute sense of course the judge just
kept saying you mean this could happen
and the lawyer kept saying yes but any
reasonable Congress is going to impeach
a president who does that if a president
is gaug in official duties you can't
criminally charge him for it unless
Congress deems it to be crimes and high
crimes and misdemeanors and the Senate
confirms through conviction and then of
course ladies and gentlemen the story
that everybody really wants to talk
about but you know we're a serious show
here secret Jewish tunnels yeah there's
a video of a Jewish man climbing out of
the sidewalk in New York City and
there's a video my favorite tweet is
Imagine witnessing this happening but
not having your phone and then trying to
explain to people that a Jewish man
climbed out of the sidewalk from a
secret tunnel underground without
sounding like an anti-semite so this
happened the police showed up they tried
filling in these secret tunnels
apparently some of these young Jewish
men started fighting with the police and
a dozen or so got arrested everybody is
wondering what the is going on there so
we'll talk about that plus a whole lot
more before we get started my friends
head over to cast brew.com if you scroll
down you will see Alex Stein Prime Time
grind two times caffeine coffee hey
ladies and gentlemen drink responsibly
drink your coffee responsibly two times
caffeine is no joke but we do have it
available because some people like
higher caffeine content in their coffee
this new coffee is accompanied by a new
commercial which we have up on a if you
go follow me at timcast onx you can
watch it Pinn to my profile starring
Alex Stein and uh you know just don't
free based coffee and don't snort coffee
but uh just drink actually just drink
your coffee responsibly but watch the
commercial it's a whole lot of fun and
by buying Casper coffee you are
supporting the show and getting the best
cup of coffee you'll ever have in your
life CU we we make a a mean cup of Joe I
got to tell you what and I'm also a big
fan of our sleepy Joe decaf and uh if uh
if you want if you're looking for a good
gift buy the Sleepy Joe uh sleepy Joe
decaf for your Democrat buddies because
uh even they will find it funny it's a
good it's a good name shout out to the
the timcast members who helped come up
with these names uh head over to
timcast.net work directly because this
show is possible thanks in part to
viewers like you as members you help
make this show possible we've got a
flight right after this show to Iowa so
that we can host a podcast slown Hall
event with vami now I must stress
inclement weather has us worried we are
being told that it the flights may be
shut down completely out of our control
but I told them we will make this happen
because a little snow is not going to
stop us so right now we're at we're
Maryland it's it's raining and it's
mostly not that big of a deal it's light
rain but in De Mo apparently it's heavy
snow and we're told that the airport we
would be landing it because it's a
private jet should be fine it's up to
the pilots however whether they want to
actually fly through this weather I
think by the time we'd be landing which
is going to be like 3:00 a.m. things
should be okay but uh let me just stress
we're going to be leaving here at 11:30
arriving at around 11: after we at the
show arriving at the airport by about
11:30 getting on a plane immediately
Landing then we've got to rush to our
hotel set up the show and I got to
record my morning morning show not a
very easy thing to do and also very
expensive but thanks to your support as
members we're able to do this and work
our fingers to the Bone to make cool
stuff happen so seriously become a
member if you appreciate the work we do
support the work we do and we're going
to have that members only show coming up
for you tonight at 10 p.m. smash the
like button right now subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
joining us tonight to talk about this
and everything else is Mayor Trent
Stags great to be with you who are who
are you what do you do besides being a
mayor I guess well I I've been uh in
Utah now in elected office for 10 years
and I'm running for United States Senate
uh have quite a business background too
help take a company public in the energy
space and have my my wife Alicia and I
have two fantastic kids and just just
proud to to be running right on which uh
what city are you the mayor of I'm the
mayor of Riverton which is just south of
Salt Lake City uh probably about 20
minutes south there and man talk about a
beautiful place it is it's it's on I
remember the first time I drove through
just the mountains on either side
Indescribable it it really is I mean
when you when you go away to somewhere
really flat like say Texas or somewhere
else and you come dropping in and you
see how tall and Majestic those
mountains are just wow every time back
go to like Chicago and the suburbs the
Great Plains just all flat nothing but
sky and buildings and then you take a
vacation you know someone like me and
you drive through Utah and you're just
it's it's it's it's amazing yeah other
areas think they have mountains we
really have mountain in Utah of course
yeah right on well thanks for that
should be fun we got Sheamus Goin my
name is Sheamus Goin I have YouTube
channel called Freedom Tunes we do
animated political cartoons we upload at
least once a week so I want to ask you
all to go over there subscribe check
that out it's a lot of fun and I'm
excited to be back on the
show how you doing everybody my name is
Phil leonti I'm the lead singer of the
heavy metal band to all their remains a
very failed musician anti-communist
encounter
revolutionary and uh I am Serge I am a
Utah man Utah man I am
and uh yeah I'm excited to have you here
sir thank you very much and let's get to
it let's go our first story from the
Washington examiner Ray EPS gets no jail
time sentenced to one-year probation a
man widely Accused by former president
Donald Trump supporters of covertly
working on behalf of the FBI during the
January 6 Capital right was sentenced
Tuesday to a year of probation for his
actions that day Ray app 62 pleaded
guilty last fall to one misdemeanor for
disorderly conduct in a restricted area
the doj had asked that EPS get 6 months
in prison a relatively harsh sentence
for that charge while EPS argued that
probation and restitution were
appropriate penalties he received
restitution of
$500 so here's the big issue and we'll
just keep it real simple for youall he's
the one guy on camera orchestrating and
I mean that literally telling people to
go into the capital if there is any
orchestrating that is documented is that
you take a look at the proud boys and O
Keepers or whatever and it's like vague
we're going to go who knows going to
happen there's no real plan it's even
admitted in these in these official
statements that they don't really have a
plan and riario was not in Washington DC
on that day they sentenced him to 20
years M Ray EPS Not only was there but
was advocating for people to go in is on
camera saying he knows he'll be arrested
for inciting this he says I don't want
to say it cuz I'll get arrested but I'll
say it and they say say and then he
tells people to go in the capital and
then there's a video of him at the front
barricade when it's first breached with
Whispering into a man's ear and then
they breach the barricades storm the
capital grounds and this guy gets
probation we have so many stories of
people like Brandon stro for instance
never went in the building prison how
about Owen Shroyer did not go in the
building
prison many people are rightly wondering
why it is this man ray apps is not
getting any jail time but more
importantly why he has been defended by
the corporate press here here's my
conspiracy Theory he's actually just as
you as everything is perfectly
straightforward and the corporate press
is defending him that's the real
conspiracy he actually is some bumbling
Trump supporter who advocated them going
to the capital and the doj is like let's
go real easy on him and get our buddies
in the press to defend him so it makes
everybody think he's the bad guy well
you know it's a very interesting
situation and the way that it's framed
is very telling so this article and many
of the other articles you'll read is Ray
UPS who right-wingers and conservatives
and cons conspiracy theorists allege was
involved with the federal government in
some capacity or needs to be punished
more harshly than he's being uh punished
rather than Ray EPS who whispered in the
ear of the first person who broke down a
barricade or Ray EPS who was inciting
the riot a day before and telling people
they should enter the capital and who
was then called a Fed they never point
out what actually happened they never
point out what the evidence shows they
always point out this is what
right-wingers think this is what
conservatives think this is what
conspiracy think think not this is what
happened right and and the important the
very very important thing about these
videos is Ray EP saying that he knows he
will be arrested for what he is about to
say and then he says it he knows what he
is saying is incitement to illegal
activities mhm and they and they avoided
charging this guy for a very long time
yep and their argument was he never set
foot in the building but like you said
Brandon straa and or Owen Shroyer are
both people who never entered the
building either and yet they were
charged and they were in prison and and
Brennan stco who we actually had on the
show had to plea down from like 20 years
or something like that they were trying
to lock him up in federal prison for a
very long time and he never the building
they lied about the evidence they said
that he was egging people on and telling
them to go into the building when when
it's not clear that he actually was
because you can't see him on camera and
according to him it's someone off camera
yelling it uh we actually have footage
of Ray EPS telling people to go in and
whispering in someone's ear and he gets
six months probation when they were
trying to charge Brandon straa and lock
him up for 20 years this is the most
blackpilling situation I think that's
going on in the United States right now
the the way that the people that are
that were at the at the capital in the
sixth are being treated um the way that
the government has
really you know set the the the
conditions so that it's clearly favoring
people and clearly going out of you know
out of its way to essentially you know
prosecute people for things that are
protected under the Constitution um and
it's it's it's blatant and the real
disheartening thing is not that the
government is doing it or people in the
government would do it because they're
all garbage anyways um it's that there
are so many Americans that support it
and this goes back to the fact that
America is going through in my opinion
America and a lot of other people too
America is currently going through a
cultural Revolution like they did like
they had in China that and what that
means is the fundamental principles that
our country is founded on and I'm not
talking about religion or any of that
kind of stuff I'm talking about simple
basic things like you are innocent until
proven guilty those things are literally
being ignored currently in regard to
January 6th in regard to Donald Trump in
regard to all any number of federal and
state cases that have have been brought
against people that have the wrong
politics people in other countries can
see this people in other countries
clearly see this whatever your opinion
on on Donald Trump when you have people
like gr Glenn Greenwald who is no Trump
fan and is no
right-winger can clearly see this and
then you can have people like that are
as silly as Alex Jones can see this and
they're both saying the same things and
the only people that don't see this are
the actual
establishment I mean it's the only
people that that if you pay attention if
you are paying attention to what's going
on it is difficult to for me to believe
that you are being honest if you can't
see that there is political persecution
and I'm glad that you pointed out that
this is very reminiscent of the cultural
revolution what we're seeing is a kind
of neoism they accuse people of being
enemies of the state or the
establishment needing of ostracization
or even imprisonment on the basis of
their political values and it's also
ranked uh based on their their ethnic
background their their IM imigrant
status whether they're conservative or
not right what Ma did is he created a
series of privileged classes and then he
told the people you have to go after the
privileged classes and to be labeled as
a member of one of these privileged
classes uh in in Ma's Cultural
Revolution was basically a death
sentence or a sentence to be imprisoned
but let me just be perfectly clear but
let me be perfectly clear that is where
this kind of thing ends you don't start
singling out ethnic groups and political
groups and start saying that they're
evil and need to be ostracized and
removed from society and just have that
stop like there's either backlash and it
stops happening or it ends up getting
violent and they try to harm people and
we already see they're trying to lock
people up on the basis of their
political values yes and what you to
your point about the identity stuff Mao
had red and black identities if you were
a communist you would you had a red
identity and they used those identities
to turn children against their parents
if your parents owned a shop or owned
property or owned everything or owned
you know owned anything or you were just
looked at unfavorably you you you
believed you were not a communist or
whatever you had a black mark on your
family and the children would go to
school and they didn't want to have
black marks they wanted to be they
wanted to have red identities they
wanted to be good Communists they wanted
to get along with their friends they
wanted that they didn't want to be weird
it was all peer pressure which is what
we're seeing now all of that stuff all
of these things are reminiscent of Ma's
Ma's cultural revolution it's happening
currently in the United States because
actual Marxism economic Marxism vulgar
Marxism does not work so they're trying
to use a racial uh a racial Vector all
of the talk about race that you're
seeing now and it's people Everyone
agrees there's constantly talk about
race that is just a vector of attack and
it's all because it's a ma Cultural
Revolution going on in the US it's crazy
to me that you have not just that
concept like you said that it's been
turned on its head innocent until proven
guilty it's that equal justice under the
law right that is the application that
is what is foundational uh to our
country and you're not seeing that
you've got this two-tier justice system
that's going going on I see it uh ever
since running for US Senate you know I'm
trying to replace Mitt Romney here uh
and going around and talking to so many
utans I've talked to many that actually
were there on January 6th and it blew me
away to listen to the story of one woman
in particular who was there with her
son-in-law they had two different judges
right um she unfortunately got the
harsher judge and for just walking
around 30 days in a federal penitentiary
she in the building in the building all
she did was walk around for I don't know
just maybe 15 minutes max and did 30
days in a federal penitentiary in
Washington state and she said I'm the
only one I know of that's done time for
a misdemeanor more time than Ray EPS
more time than Ray EPS this is what this
is what's amazing is that a large
portion of the convictions in the
January 6 cases are people who showed up
after the fact and there's no barricades
that have been ripped down the doors had
been opened by police Joe Scarboro of
MSNBC on Janu anuary 7th CNN reports he
said you opened the effing doors for
them MH so there are people who don't
know what's going on the capital is
normally open unrestricted the police
open the doors and even fan some in they
go to prison MH this is crazy what's
happening in this country and when you
look at what's going on on the southern
border I got to be honest man look I
don't think all hope is lost I certainly
think we have been winning and there's a
lot of people who don't want to accept
it but we've got tremendous cultural
victories I mean the fact that Dave
Chappelle can say the jokes that he can
say to mass Applause from from a DC
audience shows we are winning this
culture this culture War but of course
when you back an animal into a corner
they will lash out violently and as the
establishment machine begins to lose
power they are going to act irrationally
and violently and that's what we are now
seeing we are seeing people who are just
bumbling you know tourists in DC who
went to see a speech walk walked around
and go to
prison it's horribly depressing and as
mentioned earlier this all ties into
whether or not you are a member of one
of the favorite identity groups look big
bad scary white person insurrectionist
right-winger inside of the capital well
that person is going to do prison time
right or they're going to be more likely
to they're certainly going to be frowned
upon in the media that's why people are
are asking why is nothing happening to
this Ray UPS guy because he is every
single thing and he's a member of every
identity group that we're constantly
told we're supposed to hate this is an
older guy uh who seems to be working
class who's a white conservative male
who was
inciting a riot and was inciting a quote
unquote Insurrection and he he only gets
probation now don't sit here and try to
tell me that that's his white privilege
kicking in and people not wanting to
prosecute him in the system not hand
handling him because he's a white guy or
because conservatives are actually
secretly privileged and we're getting
this wrong because other conservative
leaning people who are more politically
active have gotten in far more trouble
in this instance for far less the
reality is there is information that's
being withheld for us on his involvement
that that's all I'll say I always he did
more to incite the riot that or to
incite violence incite uh the the riots
and stuff than Donald Trump did
absolutely Don without question without
question it is it is I would be remissed
if I did not end this segment on January
6 by pointing out the facts of the case
that Jan 6 was an inside job was
adjudicated as an inside job and is as a
matter of fact based on CNN's reporting
January 6 was an inside job but don't
take my word for it first let me give
you the definition of inside job from
the Oxford dictionary inside job is
defined as a crime committed by or with
the assistance of a person living or
working on the premises where it
occurred notice they say committed by or
with the assistance of inside job is a
fairly broad term it means that someone
someone inside allowed or helped or
assisted in this happening of course
then we have this story from CNN man who
said January 6 was magical acquitted in
US capital Riot case a federal judge
found Matthew Martin not guilty of four
Federal misdemeanors four related to
trespassing Martin had successfully
argued that a US capital officer waved
him into the building at least one video
played during the trial appeared to show
an officer moving his arm in a waving
motion that is to say CNN has confirmed
a video exist of an officer waving at
Matthew Martin for which Matthew Martin
interpreted as being waved into the
building and that a judge agreed that
the police officer appeared to be waving
him into the building by all means CNN
you are allowed to argue that he was
waving at police officers but that's not
the point with the assistance of a
capital police officer this man entered
the building but don't take my word for
it why don't you oh do I not I'm sorry
I've made a terrible mistake I did not
pull up the uh Joe Scarboro article I
pulled up the the vron uh sorry silly me
Joe scarb lambasted Capital police you
opened the effing doors for them CNN
reports and that's it without refuting
they report Joe Scaro saying outright
they politely opening the door for
terrorists who had scrolled on the door
murder the media he
added Joe scar bro's argument is that
these people were violent terrorists and
the police opened the doors politely for
them
why let me just get a show of hands how
many of you would view that as
assistance that's assistance uh uh one
two three that is everyone in the room
raising their hand that police politely
opening the door for what Joe Scaro
calls terrorist as assisting them I
don't see why police would politely open
the door according to Joe scarbo so
according to MSNBC and CNN there is
adjudicated a judge said cop waved this
guy in so it appears well that sounds
like it's reasonable to say it was an
inside job so when they claim the ramas
Swami was wrong that it was an inside
job the said it appeared to be why
certainly based on CNN's own reporting
it does appear to be an inside job but I
would say considering we know the police
did open the doors took selfies with
people so much so that MSNBC got very
angry about it and CNN even reported on
both instances inside job is beyond
confirmed in every conceivable way thank
you for uh coming to my TED Talk
but I suppose now we can uh jump to the
next story in the January 6 case this is
from The Daily Mail judge asks Trump
lawyer if president would be immune from
prosecution for using SEAL Team Six to
assassinate a political rival in
explosive courtroom Showdown this is a
really really great story and it's a
very important story for all of you this
is an excellent way to help people
understand that these issues in law are
nuanced and the headline does not
accurately portray what is being uh uh
the information being conveyed first let
me start by Shocking All of You by
saying it is a fact and it is true in
this argument it makes absolute sense
and it is reasonable and rational to
argue if the president ordered the
assassination of his political rival you
could not prosecute him unless he has
been impeached and convicted already
that's the statement the judges tried to
make it seemed like it was some
egregious and shocking thing that such
an argument would be made but it does
make sense because there actually is an
official AR an argument for an official
course of action in which a president or
politician would assassinate their rival
I'll give you a simple
explanation president a learns through
the Senate intelligence committee or or
the house intelligence committee or
whatever Foreign Affairs top secret
information that a political rival of
his has been making deals with a foreign
adversary and is going to be meeting
with them in a foreign country to
deliver top secret nuclear code
information from the United States
Unfortunately they discovered this much
too late and they need to put a stop to
it the president goes to a federal judge
who reviews the evidence the arguments
are made and a warrant is issued the
president then orders this man must be
stopped by any means necessary after
this political rival is caught in the
act of selling State Secrets an act of
treason when US forces try to apprehend
and arrest him he resists and draws a
weapon and is killed by the president's
forces the assassination of a political
rival now perhaps you can argue that
they mean like just taking him out in
that instance as I described it there
would be no impeachment Congress would
say no we were the ones that delivered
the intelligence that this man had
betrayed his country and a judge signed
off on the warrant for his for his
apprehension and or execution for
treason in which case you could not
prosecute the president pres for taking
this action as no one in Congress would
believe a crime had been committed now
if Donald Trump or any president just
straight up killed their political rival
for political power instantly in
Congress they would be impeached and
convicted and then they could be
criminally charged the important thing
to understand here is that were this to
not be the case as Democrats are arguing
this could mean that states or elements
of the federal government could
criminally charge a president whenever
they feel like it before before during
or after they even in office if they
feel threatened by him and the founding
fathers were concerned this would
disrupt the political process a man
announces he's going to run for office
so what happens a rival political actor
in government decides I'll criminally
charge him so that he can't win and
that's exactly where we are yeah no um
it's interesting right because it it's
really a question of process as you
mentioned so saying something like he
would have to be impeached first is like
saying he would have to be arrested
first it's just part of the process
doesn't mean it's something he's allowed
to do it means that we actually have a
process laid out for how that's taken
care of this this seems like there is a
process here uh Trump's lawyers have
made a completely sound argument that I
believe is correct you can't accuse a
president of committing crime so in in
this instance we're talking about Trump
investigating voter fraud it's actually
the duty of the the executive branch to
investigate voter fraud should there be
any but because there's a conflict of
interest in that it was Trump's election
they're arguing it was a criminal
activity well I believe it is correct
Trump should be H uh he there should be
an investigation as to conflict of
interest the determination was uh he was
impeached and then he was acquitted How
Could You criminally charge someone
who's been acquitted for this very thing
they're going after him why the
arguments to the Supreme Court are the
point of the Democrat process create oh
so they're in a federal a federal
appeals court right now and making these
arguments on immunity and the Supreme
Court is going to hear Trump's case on
the ballot uh issue but right now if
these judges come out and say the
president is not immune then we are
inching towards absolute dictatorship
and the collapse of the
Republic oh boy yeah that's a pretty
great takedown um great analysis right
there because you're right there is a
process there is procedure that we have
to go through I mean the the he has to
be impeached he has to be convicted uh
in the Senate that hasn't happened here
and um I there is that is the argument
exactly that attorneys are making is
they have a presidential immunity that
it is there for the reasons that you've
cited this this case they're bringing
against him is the offense it it the
offense is not to criminally charge
Trump that's a byproduct the offensive
attack against our Republic is this for
the judges to rule presidents can be
criminally charged then the next time an
America first cand let's say let's say
in eight years vras Swami is is the
front runner what will happen federal
agents to prevent him from winning will
file criminal charges against him let's
say he actually gets elected let's say
let's say there's a back room deal and
he goes to the establishment and says
look there's a few things that I want to
do for this country but I agree to play
ball with you on term on foreign policy
they say okay then he gets elected and
says no I'm going to play things my way
they go okay you're under arrest we're
going to criminally charge you now it
doesn't matter who you are if you're the
president or not it doesn't matter if
the people want you elected if the
Democrats win the ability to criminally
charge the sitting president no election
will ever matter ever
again yeah I mean I think that that does
make sense and I'm not I mean I don't
have a whole lot of faith in in most of
the judges and and judicial system that
is trying Trump I think that most of
these uh most of these cases should have
been thrown out um I think the one in uh
about the what was it actually no I'm
not I think they maybe maybe Georgia has
something but either way um so I don't
have any faith that they're going to
that that the judge will decide you know
in a in a fair way if you listen to
these judges you would come to the
conclusion they will not judge in a fair
way I mean so so I mean as much as again
this is this goes back to my point why
so why I'm so blackpilled I don't think
that the justice system is treating any
of this fairly and it and the people
that are that are Prosecuting tend to be
Democrats you know the the opposing
party the it just doesn't I don't see
how this is in any way Fair how why the
American people aren't aren't saying
look this is clearly political and and
more noise about this well yeah I mean
why would we expect a fair outcome when
none of this is fair to begin with the
fact that he's even gone to trial Donald
Trump has been more investigated and
he's been more Pro um he's had more
charges brought up against him than any
president in recent history and are you
going to sit here with a straight face
and tell me he's been the most corrupt
that's ridiculous more corrupt than
George Bush more corrupt than Bill
Clinton more corrupt than uh Barack
Obama it's completely
inanity we we are absolutely watching
the erosion of the of the Republic we we
did you guys see uh uh was it a couple
days ago that senator from New Hampshire
said quote a democracy if you can keep
it embarrassing embarrassing
intentionally erasing history why here's
here's what I try to explain to people
democracy does not mean rule by majority
they think it does democracy means rule
by the absolute slimmest of minorities
what people think a democracy will be 10
people ask what's for lunch and everyone
votes people think democracy means six
people say we want pepperoni pizza
congratulations you got pepperoni pizza
I'll tell you what democracy is at
Occupy Wall Street they needed a way to
keep supplies dry so they used to have
these things called General assemblies
where the whole group of occupy gets
together and then they'll you know
petition everybody and then raise their
hands and wiggle their fingers if they
like things the idea was hey we had a
bunch of clothes and supplies that are
getting wet from the rain we need
plastic bins to store them so if it
rains or snows they will not be
destroyed simple right well you'd think
in a democracy
the average person assumes you're going
to get a yes or no vote right that's not
what happened what happened was
everybody said all in favor of buying
the bins the NOS have it why well
plastic is bad for the environment so we
can't have plastic okay well what's the
solution there's no other material
you're not going to get a glass one
you're not going to get a w a wooden
sealed basket with rubber or anything
right well how about this how about we
get recycled reused bins so that way
we're not contributing okay now we've
got a propos here all in favor of
recycled plastic bins the NOS have it
why because was this sourced fair trade
were the workers treated properly I'm
not kidding this happened eventually
what happens is in a
democracy there is only a tiny
percentage that actually wants the
outcome and the majority of people
compromise with each other to create
some wacky outcome that makes no sense
the end result Was the vote that won was
recycled fair trade plastic bins that
are bought off of Craigslist and you
can't spend more than x amount so what
happened well that's clearly impossible
so the people who had access to the
money just went to I went I believe they
went to a super like a department store
and just bought standard plastic bins
for 20 bucks and then brought them in
there and then just said sure we did
what you we wanted if everybody gets a
vote on how to run something you don't
get a simple majority you get this weird
amalgamation of the of the desires of as
many people as possible and then the
result is how many people came out and
filled up a form saying I want this
specific kind of plastic bin three out
of 100 and that's who wins in the end
that's direct democracy well so this is
actually something a good friend of mine
pointed out he said like have you ever
tried to make dinner plans with multiple
people hell it's like it's it's really
difficult but you know what works out
really well when like you're a kid and
you're in the car with your parents and
your dad's like here's where we're going
going for dinner and then you just go
there and you pick what you want off the
menu right but but where these things
always end up is one person just making
the decision anyway so we're kind of
fooling ourselves if we think we really
have this process where everyone's
actually coming together and getting
what they want dude I got an idea we
should totally do this so freedoman um
our new studio is done the I should say
the new structure the buildings past
inspection it is it is done all we're
doing now is the main the actual
technical buildup for the studio and
then we'll be there in a few weeks we
let's make a video
where we give everyone 10 options for
dinner dessert oh let's just do this
let's just let's just do uh uh dinner
we'll say here's a list of meats here's
a list of carbs here's a list of
vegetables vote for which one you like
the
most do you think you're going to get a
delicious eggplant Parmesan with fresh
ricot on top no you're going to get like
a beef steak with a scoop of vanilla ice
cream espresso poured around it some
asparagus stock sticking out of it and
you're going to be like I am not eating
this but hey that's what everyone voted
for M most people wanted beef most
people wanted ice cream most people
wanted asparagus most people wanted
espresso and then you're going to be
like welcome to democracy yeah it's it
it's and it's been referred to as the
Tyranny tyranny of the minority right uh
under that scenario and that's there's
been a concerted effort for decades now
to take control of that word and to
foist it up democracy let's save our
democracy mean I get so sick and tired
of seeing this too we're seeing
democracy 2024 that's not what our
country is we're a constitutional
republic it's a their country it that's
right and and I've heard you say this
before where words really have meaning
and Democrats on the left are so good at
co-opting that and just putting that out
there time and again when they when they
say our democracy they're not including
you no that's right they really mean our
yeah it's like the way the way I've
described it is three guys break into
your house start destroying your living
room and when you walk in and say get
out of my house one burglar looks at the
other burglar and says he's trying to
kick us out of our house yeah he's not
calling it your house he's not acting
like you're a part of his his
plans yeah no it's absolutely right it's
it's always so funny to me because for
years and years what the left did in
what they did within the popular culture
is they made people laugh at these
American buzzwords right so they said oh
come on conservatives and right wiers
talk about freedom and freedom just the
word became a punchline oh it's freedom
oh it's America uh and of course you say
it in a Southern accent cuz that's
that's Peak comedy um and now they'll go
our democracy this is about our
democracy which is hilarious they're
just they're like throwing around these
like dim store patriotic terms without
actually thinking about the ideas
they're expressing like what do you mean
by that like why is this good for
democracy why is it good for democracy
to remove the front runner of the
Republican primaries out of the process
because they're saying our democracy
they're not saying democracy our demra
agree that's my point they're just
throwing this around as a buzz word no
no no no no the elite know what they
doing I'm arguing with you on this I'm
saying you incorrect I'm saying that I I
don't know how much we disagree because
the elite are using it that way but I
think your average person who hears that
and throws that around or thinks it
sounds good doesn't detect it my point
is it they're saying the fact that
Donald Trump could win is a threat to
our plan that's what the Press is saying
so there's uh a couple people that are
running for the Democratic primary and I
forget the guy's name or whatever but he
tweeted out Me and Mar Williamson are
not insurrectionists why are they
blocking our primary and I said because
you running in an election is a threat
to their power structure the quote
unquote democracy they have is not a
democracy of the people it's a de
democratic system of the elites where
they get to decide and if you actually
ran against them you would threaten
their power structure absolutely I'm not
talking about that I agree with you that
they have a kind of old oligarchy and
they're trying to preserve their power
but when the reason they seize on to
these words like democracy is because
they know you're average person who
doesn't have time to research or think
about these things hears that and goes
like Oh democracy that's a good word
this is about
democracy yeah I I think to a certain
degree but my point is that they're
literally saying we are trying to build
a new communist system yep that we we
would call like like North Korea calls
their country the Democratic Republic of
North Korea yeah good point People's
Republic of China so they're saying our
democracy is they might as well be
saying our communist Ator they saying
they're saying this election Communist
dictatorship is on the ballot they call
it democracy mhm yeah because that's a
nice word he used good word I like when
he uses good word when he used good word
he's right right this goes this goes
back you're against good word this goes
back yes I am against good word um this
goes back to uh this goes back to to the
the point about maoism because that was
something that Mao said like communism
is the idea of Communism is pure
democracy he's not entirely wrong you
know and and it it will destroy
the Republic which is the intent you
know the and there's as it's frustrating
when you talk to people that get their
news from John Stewart or from Comedy
Central and they believe all of the the
the messages that are coming out of
Comedy Central and that's that's really
one of the most damaging things that
that's happened to the to the US has
been the ability of of The Daily Show to
just feed people the most insane
propaganda and have the most ridiculous
framing of anything conservative and
it's really been toxic because it's
affected the way that PE like you were
saying about freedom and stuff the way
that people
perceive things that are fundamental to
the United States and the left really
does has gotten to the point where they
hate America they hate liberalism you
talk to any leftist and they they don't
call themselves Liber liberals they call
themselves progressives I like Jimmy
Kimel one this really long rant about
Aaron Rogers and it was the stupidest
thing ever because he was like calling
someone a pedo isn't an opinion
and he threatened to Sue Aaron Rogers
but then he goes on to say he read about
the Dunning Krueger effect where people
are too stupid to realize they're stupid
he said ignorant but I love this because
uh he should have talked to his lawyer
because publicly stating that you
believe the person who defamed you is
too stupid to realize they defamed you
is an affirmative defense for the person
who defamed you under times V Sullivan
in which case if he ever did Sue Aaron
Rogers could say Jimmy Kimmel admitted
it I genuinely believed what I had said
and you know
missed you know um Jimmy Kimmel also
made a dig at him for going to Community
College which is hysterical how many of
these leftists complain about how
expensive college is and about how
horrible the student debt crisis is only
to turn around and laugh at people who
took responsibility and said I'm going
to go somewhere less expensive I'm going
to go somewhere where I won't rack up a
lot of debt none of them believe any of
the things they're saying all about
status it's all about hierarchy all
about kissing their own I want to point
out Aaron Rogers never said Jimmy Kimmel
was on the list he said Jimmy Kimmel is
probably worried the list may come out
and the interpretation by most people
was that he was implying Kimmel was on
the list maybe or I stated this before
the Epstein documents were released and
there's more coming out every day uh
Jimmy Kimmel came out and said I've
never met with EP I never flew on his
plane well Aaron Rogers didn't say that
but I actually think there's a very good
reason that Jimmy Kimel is Sweating
Bullets Over these documents and that is
it has been reported that he was in
business with uh what's the guy's name
Andrew Perry Lang he was in business
with Epstein's personal chef who owned a
restaurant I think it was called APL
Jimmy Kimmel was good friends with him
Jimmy Kimmel may be worried about the
release of this not because he's on the
list he could be peripherally mentioned
but because his good friend is on the
list so Aaron Rogers said a very basic
statement which probably is true Jimmy
Kimmel has reason to be worried
and and it's not just uh Perry Lang it's
many people in Hollywood who may appear
on these lists who are friends with
Jimmy Kimmel so if those lists come out
and it turns out that a good friend of
Jimmy Kimmel was deeply involved in
what's going on with Epstein and it's
true this guy was Epstein's personal
chef Jimmy Kimmel may be worried that
could damage his brand or his net worth
or something even though he's not
accused of being a pedo yeah I mean look
if if you're not willing to be friends
with pedophiles you're not going to have
very many friends in Hollywood I know
you you'd basically just be by yourself
hanging out
and then you make a documentary where
they they call you all a liar even
though you're a victim how about we jump
to this story ladies and gentlemen it's
the moment you've all been waiting for
Newsweek says secret tunnel under New
York synagogue Sparks katak scenes but I
will not bury the lead I will simply
just play for you this video so you can
all say holy what the is going
on for those that are listening the
video depicts a Jewish man climbing out
of a secret tunnel in the sidewalks of
New York City swatting at the camera and
then running away it looks like a skit
and uh again my favorite tweet from this
is uh imagine seeing a Jewish man climb
out of an underground tunnel in New York
sidewalk not having your camera to film
it and trying to explain to your friends
what you saw without sounding like an
anti-semite it's already been a wild
year man it is insane so the story is
there's a Secret Tunnel built under a
New York synagogue the police show up
cement trucks come to fill in the tunnel
soiled mattresses are pulled from this
crevice young men then rip the walls
down this wood paneling and break
through the wall to try and occupy the
space to stop the the construction Crews
from cementing it in when the police
show up young Jewish men fight the
police and a dozen are arrested and now
everyone is saying what the is going on
with secret Jewish tunnels in New York
City the Jews are hanging out with the
teenage mutant nin Turtles um so I have
a friend that that would be the cool
explanation that would be the fun one um
I have a friend that is a uh young
Jewish man that lives in lives on Long
Island and he sent me some information
about this apparently there is a sect of
young Jewish men that are considered uh
they're Israelis from a sec a fringe
sect of Judaism to come to the US as
teenagers to study with little to no
supervision they have no money awful
living conditions in no regard for
anyone or anything outside of their
ridiculous beliefs that essentially
amount to treating the lug Luba viter
rebe who passed away in the 90s as a
deity they consider him to be the
Messiah and refuse to acknowledge that
he is no longer alive the rumor is that
they dug the tunnel so they'd have
unrestricted access to the main
synagogue here when it's closed as it
was for a bit during covid um the
apparently the rebi used to give dollars
out every Sunday along with other
blessings people would line up so he was
an icon and there there are there's a
sect of Judaism that thinks he is the
Messiah and I apparently they had a
underground tunnel to because they were
fighting the man so do you think that's
what this is look when I when I saw the
police coming in and then these young
men start fighting cops I'm like
zealotry immed ideological Zealot
zealotry there's no there's there's 0%
chance you save this tunnel once they've
discovered it the idea that a dozen
young Jewish men could fight the police
off and preserve this was insane the
only reason they would then do it is if
they ideology was stronger than their
logic in their minds they're thinking I
know we'll lose but for this reason we
must fight to protect our secret
tunnel uh yeah I I think it's hilarious
I I've got the wikip the guy that
they're talking about that has passed
away his name is menachim Mendel schne
schneerson I swear to God I'm not making
this up I'm going to copy the Wikipedia
on the guy I got it right here yeah so
menm mendal schneerson yeah so he he's
he's he's dead yeah but they believe he
was what a deity or something this this
particular sect apparently believes that
he was he is the Messiah and uh uh he
was he was well- loved by by people in
the community and and I guess in in
according to Jews and stuff but uh there
there are people lead of the Shabad
luich movement how do how do the tunnels
come into play here though that's they
didn't want to be held down by the man
they wanted to be able to get to
synagogue man oh this was because of
lockdown that's what people say that's
what people say but it's it's years
later now right there they're still not
locked down so why would people still I
got to be honest if if young men built
tunnels so they could go and and worship
their First Amendment right when the
oppressive dictatorship of the state was
trying to suppress their constitutional
right that's based yeah I mean 100%
don't fight cops but what yeah but what
are like what are they still doing down
there if it's I guess if you have a cool
tunnel like you still use the cool
tunnel but it's I I don't know if that's
the explanation they are men there's got
to be something else yeah there's a very
interesting uh question to be had in
this case what we saw in New York with
the shutting down of churches and
synagogues was
unconstitutional judges had ruled it
unconstitutional and Cuomo said go ahead
I'll just make another executive order
and shut these things down the people
who were committing the crimes were the
police officers trying to stop people
from expressing their first amendment
rights the Constitution is the law of
the land in which case these young men
who built a tunnel to be able to go into
synagogue to worship when they were
being oppressed by the dictatorship by
the communist authorities were they were
in the
right yes clearly I mean the lockdowns
were the the most clearly
unconstitutional especially when in the
context of people that wanted to go and
practice their religion I personally am
not a Believer but it's protected in the
in the Constitution clearly there's no
there's
no ambiguity about you you know you have
the right to assemble and you have the
right right to practice your religion
there's you know I mean the or the the
the country can't make the state can't
make a uh laws regarding religion so
clearly they they had no authority to do
that and there's been there's been no
you know nothing's happened since nobody
lost their jobs no one got fired you
know and and and let's let's let's segue
this story about secret Jewish tunnels
in the most likely and appropriate
Direction mhm Civil War so when uh we
are now dealing with a question of at
what point let me let me let me put this
way this show is always about being on
the correct side of law don't break the
law you handle things appropriately if
the cops come to stop you you comply and
then you fight in court because fighting
a cop on the street doesn't do anything
for you there are limits however and
people ask this question at what point
must you defy a police officer well
obviously if the police officer is
committing a crime you are not obeying
the law by obeying a police officer
who's committing a crime right like if a
cop went and was robbing a bank and then
ordered you under threat of law to help
fill his duffel bags you should not do
that I mean well I'm not going to tell
you what to do because if he's
threatening your life yeah but if he
says if you don't do this I'll arrest
you I'd be like bro you're the one
committing the crime I'm not going to do
this here in lies the Big Challenge we
are dangerously close to this point nay
we are already in it where we are seeing
police officers engage in illegal
activity we are seeing border officers
engage in illegal activity and this this
issue of the tunnel under the synagogue
brings up a really important question
sooner or later it will be impossible to
answer what is the right side of the law
so again what we say is you see a video
of a guy and he's being stopped by the
police and he fights the cops and the
cops defend themselves and the guy dies
and then everyone's like oh the cops
racist and I'm like dude if a cop is
stopping you don't fist fight him you
keep your mouth shut you put your hands
behind your back then you get in touch
with your lawyer and you win in the
system which we have built to to to deal
with these things but what happens when
the police are shutting down churches
illegally and now the police are
basically kidnapping and threatening you
with violence without actual Authority
the problem there is the New York City
Government asserts the authority to do
it the Constitution says otherwise and
the judges have said
otherwise how would we Advocate would we
tell you no these cops are committing
crimes you should ignore them then
YouTube says Nope the cops are always
right what's what's the stance that the
the broadcasters will take you liter
honestly in a real if you're going to
actually talk about this as a realistic
situation the cop's got a gun you do
what the cop says the long and short of
it the guy with the gun is the one that
you listen to get out of that situation
because you're not going to win a
gunfight and the and the government's
not going to say okay this is good no no
no no no hold on hold on a guy shows up
wearing a badge that says the new
Republic of New York and he's got a gun
and he's wearing a uniform and he says
you now are under my jurisdiction we
assert Authority here do you listen to
him uh you you are at that point there
there's someone trying to force you to
do something that is illegal you you
have been kidnapped by that guy and you
get away from them you escape if
possible my point my my my point here is
that you're making the assumption that
the person wearing the badge of New York
City is operating under any kind of
constitutional Authority no I'm making I
mean by saying you should Escape I'm
making the assumption that they're
illegitimate the point here is this this
is a point that I've made numerous times
as it pertains to these stories what
happens if someone knocks on your door
and you go and there's a clown in total
clown Garb standing there and you're
like who are you what do you want and he
says I am the clown Bureau and we are
here to arrest you we have a warrant
would you actually listen to the clown
Bureau I mean look the ATF shows up at
everybody's house every now and again
right the point is you clearly recognize
a man in a clown costume is no legal
Authority that's absurd what happens
when a a person shows up claiming to be
law enforcement but the view and the
confidence in the system is thus that
you look at it like a clown costume like
the easier way to explain it is a guy
shows up wearing a bad you're in
California and he has a new California
Republic badge sheriff and you're like
there's no such thing as the new
California Republic so you're
essentially asking what happens when the
government loses legitimacy with the
average person when the authorities do
what happens when it's split and no one
knows fair enough so right now it's very
simple to say if the police show up you
just you you you here to the system you
get a lawyer you fight it the best way
possible which is in the courts but what
if the police start killing people what
if what if a police officer what if what
if uh uh uh I mean look let's let's just
entertain what this tunnel that they
built allegedly was so that they could
keep going to church to synagogue when
they were illegally barred from doing so
we saw in New York the police were
barricading Parks locking them up and
shutting down schools they were spying
on schools there was one video where a
guy's restaurant was closed had his door
open because he was cleaning and a
health inspector came in and gave him a
fine for being open he goes I'm not open
I'm closed and they were like your door
is open and he was like What if someone
claims they have the authority of
government and are violating the law we
cannot Advocate that you adhere to a man
who's breaking the law that would be
telling you to actually be party to law
Breakers but we have seen police break
the law under color of law we are we are
at this point right now since Co and the
question's all the question more ser
iously is on the southern border federal
law enforcement are assisting illegal
immigration they're committing crimes
yeah this is why I got to say this is
why it's so important elections matter
elections have consequences right we
have to have people in an executive role
or in government that are representing
us they're supposed to be representing
us that are looking out for our and this
this Co example Rings true in my own
Community where I was a mayor and I said
no I said no to mask mandates no to
vaccine Mand I is one of the very few I
had our County uh County authorities
call me and say you need to be enforcing
social distancing at your parks and your
cops your city cops they need to be
enforcing mask mandates and handing out
fines and I said go pound sand I mean
this is this is not and that's what we
need to do we need to find people that
have exhibited that type of courage and
that backbone and and support them in
office otherwise we get what we have
today I think that I whereas I do think
that the point you're making is is
correct I think that it
is far worse of a situation in that it's
not about finding people that are
running that's that have these policies
or that are talking about these policies
it's like con it's convincing the people
that are voting that these are the
correct policies I think that the the
the there are people that say Hey I
would do this I would do that that that
that are at least pointing in the right
direction and I feel like the average
person has been again talking what we're
talking about earlier what I was
mentioning earlier how the average
person has been so so indoctrinated by
the the by comedy centrals you know a
call on politics that they don't have
any understanding of why the policies
that they're hoping for won't work at
all they don't have any understanding of
history and and I think that that's the
majority of our problem is the people
that have the people that that are now
in HR departments and in and work in
government and stuff like that and and
and
leading in polit polit in political
positions in in cities Across America
they've all been taught that liberalism
is not actually the system that we
should be supporting and so I think we
need people we need we need a society
that values these things and unless we
have that we can guarantee that they're
going to vote for frivolous ridiculous
things that don't work yeah I I want to
ask you uh a question about this because
one thing that we're constantly saying
on the show and one thing I think
basically everyone in this sphere is is
saying non-stop is that we need people
to actually stand up for their values
it's great to have the right ideas it's
fantastic to know what's going on but
ultimately when push comes to show you
have to be willing to stand up for them
so I'm curious what inspired you to
actually take a stand and say we're not
doing this mask mandate stuff and when
did you reach this conclusion because I
could just say personally when this all
first started happening I want to say
for the first like couple weeks I was a
little nervous right and I thought maybe
this is something and I will wear a mask
but I want to say by the time we got to
April or May um I I was really not with
it anymore and then I I just remember
when the media was completely okay with
BLM rioting and when doctors literally
signed a note saying that that was
acceptable I went oh it was just
nonsense um but yeah I'm curious like at
what point did you come to this
conclusion and what um inspired you to
stick to your guns there cuz a lot of
people weren't a lot of elected leaders
were not no no and sadly that's true um
but I think just inherently I knew that
this was wrong and uh right away in
about March of 2020 uh I went on and
said quite uh vociferously that I was
opposed to any mask mandates whatsoever
then news came back around uh in May I
believe it was of 2020 where I said yet
again look I am not going to be
utilizing my Police Department to
enforce these things I think it's
heavy-handed this is not constitutional
and maintain that stance for you know
for the entire time so I it is I I think
you're absolutely right Phil that we
have unfortunately it's not just certain
media channels but it's the it's the
educational system that we have in this
country where we have dumbed it down so
bad and more than that we're actually
teaching people the wrong things we have
so few people that are I think
economically and civically literate yep
and that's it's just unfortunate um or
just literate we were talk no I mean we
were talking about this ear and I'm not
just talking about low reading scores
what I'm saying is with widespread
literacy it seems as if we became
satisfied teaching people to be able to
sound out letters and then know what the
word was without actually being able to
truly comprehend the deeper message of
what's being said this this this is a a
typical argument against Mass literacy
programs that I've heard from I'm not
against Mass literacy programs I just
think like they're not real literacy
programs we're teaching people like how
to sound words out we're not actually
teaching them how to really truly read
there was this great article I read a
long time ago one of the things that
played a factor in me not going to
college that argued that college is
great for the people who've decided
college is the path for them in that you
uh grow up building computers and you
want to go somewhere where you can learn
to build computers better you have the
capability to build computers and you
want to learn from the best what we did
then is we said everyone should go to
college no matter what the problem there
is this article said something like you
need an average IQ of about 110 to
actually go to Higher Learning that
means you can read and and not just
memorize but actually comprehend the
idea that is uh uh that is shown to you
and the problem now is by telling
everyone to go to college people of 100
IQ will easily memorize the literature
but not actually understand what it
means what ends up happening then is
after a few years they'll have this
jumbled up confused concept which they
think will make them smart they think
they're smarter than everybody they
actually have no idea what they're
talking about MH that I think is a good
example of what's happening in this
country you see a lot of that also you
know people will will throw stat around
they'll mention like oh yeah to to
graduate from college like on average
your IQ is going to be around 110 115
but I think that's outdated uh I I'm
almost certain that's not the case
anymore I think I think the average
college grad probably has an IQ of like
105 maybe maybe 100 even well the
average IQ is 100 that's the point no no
that's what I'm saying I don't think the
average college grad is that far above
average anymore agree I don't think
they're 110 115 yeah I think the issue
is often brought up we have a lot of
midwit in the political space these are
people who are slightly smarter than
average but not really smart enough to
grasp these these broader Concepts and
so you you end up with uh you know an
example would be when Alise stonic
says I will certify the El she's asked
will you commit to certifying the 2024
election she says yes if it's
constitutional and then NBC because
these people are scumbags and they're
evil report a leis stonic refuses to
commit to certifying the 2024 election
the midwit is the Democrat who then goes
whoa
oh they understand enough of politics
they read into it but they're not smart
enough to grasp how they're being
manipulated they don't have a minute to
think like well wait a minute when
should somebody certify election or
commit to certifying an election they
just like whoa they didn't do the good
thing they're saying they won't do the
good thing salt in cookies did you know
that you put salt in your cookies when
you make them yes how many people have
you ever run into because I've run into
a lot where they get mad I've been in
numerous occasions where I've been
baking cookies and when I put when I
pulled the salt out they said don't put
salt in it what are you doing because
they thought you don't put salt in
desserts which you literally do wow but
there are a lot
of those must be terrible knowing those
cookies they didn't put any salt in them
yeah but a lot of they don't understand
the point of putting salt in food right
and so they think cookies have sugar not
salt don't put salt in it someone who is
smart enough to understand recipes can
make cookies but not smart enough to
understand that yeah sometimes things
sound counterintuitive it goes back to
our educational system because they have
they don't they don't teach I mean the
whole the whole word educate I think in
Greek or Latin is to discover within
right and and that used to be the
process you would go and actually try to
become educated you would learn you
would have deductive reasoning critical
you know critical reasoning skills so
you would learn not just reading writing
and arithmetic but you would learn how
to debate somebody right you'd have
these conversations I mean try pulling
an average person in on this show and
have them just think and debate I mean
that just sadly that's not happening and
I think it's it's endemic of the
educational system that we have today
people just can't think for themselves
so so that is part and partial what I
think you're going to say that that's uh
that's really a communist uh
ideolog give somebody here you go no I
was just going to bring up the fact that
man on a street uh is is a thing that
everybody does for a reason because
there are plenty of plenty of hilarious
people out there so I want to pull up
this uh this story here is a tweet from
Mike
Ben he says watch this incredible moment
that a watch the incredible moment that
a rep from the Pentagon psychological
operations research firm pitched NATO's
military scup Center on turning Taylor
Swift into an asset for the Western
military Alliance to stop disinformation
on the internet excuse me well let me
play first the beginning so the first
one that's the most famous um and the
most um most common is working with
famous people um more main influencers
to share uh information or a particular
message okay now I'm going to pause real
quick the image being displayed at scon
that's a cycon it says identification
and segmentation in the identification
era it shows Taylor Swift and it says
goal identify key actors to train and
spread desire me desired messaging
example encourage opinion leaders to
share counter IO content risk opinion
leaders may not want to share content or
may accidentally share misleading
content let's play more I include Taylor
Swift in here because are you
kidding
me so yes Mike is clearly uh enjoying
that they've included Taylor Swift in
here but I must
stress many people have been accusing
Taylor Swift of being a scop or being in
on psychological operations to some
degree this is an example being given
from what I can see here in this clip
the woman did not say we literally are
working with Taylor Swift she says I use
Taylor Swift as an
example that being said what people need
to understand about uh the potential for
psychological operations and high level
influen or in on it it's that you know
uh who was it I think I was talking to
to Sheamus about this earlier we were
talking about who's possibly a Fed in
media yeah we're talking about Ray EPS
we have our we have a little um
corkboard with Tim takes Polaroids of
people when they do the podcast and we
put them on the cor a bun yarn red
string we tie around the thumb it and
we're trying to figure it out so we
actually we weed a couple out I think
but uh we were talking about who may
actually be feds M let me let me inform
all of you guys there are no feds you
know there there are feds there are
federal informants but the idea that
people working in media are secretly
Federal informant is just absolutely not
the case the idea that Taylor Swift is a
Handler I would say is absolutely not
the case but I will tell you what is
very likely the case I explained this a
long time ago and I'll explain it to you
all again you can go on run Google ads
and choose to run advertisements of any
sort on any channel you want so let's
say you want a particular kind of
political content to be successful if
the CIA or the FBI wanted certain
messaging to be dominant in this country
all they would have to do is create a
proxy company go onto Google ads buy ads
at at high rates on an individual's
Channel let's say they like freedom
Sheamus's Channel and they say his
content he's producing why is well well
let's put it this way let's let's let's
let's accuse timcast let's go with
timcast we are anti-establishment but
we're not super far right or anything
like that we're fairly moderate on the
political positions but we're very
anti-establishment notice he he had to
switch to timcast to make that point
he's like freedom freedom Tunes is just
too far out there but so the the
argument would be this if the federal
government liked that for instance after
Donald Trump was defeated by Joe Biden
in the 2020 election and I don't mean
fairly I'm quite I'm literally saying
Biden is in the White House they the
feds then go you know look we got a
bunch of conservatives over here saying
Trump won then we got someone like Tim P
who almost agrees with them on all these
other issues so he's got a big portion
of the audience but he is saying Joe
Biden won what did they do nobody emails
me nobody comes here knocks on the door
and says Mr pool we'd like to pay you to
say these things for us what they do is
they target people who they think have
the message they like by ads in like
indiscriminately and just uh discreetly
on Google and what I mean is they'll
just indiscriminately as in they'll pull
up a big thing of people and just throw
money at them and they don't care what
you say they don't ask you to say things
they just funnel money secretly through
an automated programmatic system so when
people argue that Taylor Swift is a scop
they don't need to send someone to ask
you to do it what what happens is Taylor
Swift makes music people like it Taylor
Swift then says I'm voting for Biden and
KLA Harris they say you know we really
like that message let's uh let's use one
of our proxy companies to sponsor her
next tour and give her a million dollars
that million dollars will go towards her
expanding her
business that's the game yeah that's how
they run scops yeah we were talking
about this also you got to remember like
it's not as if you have to pay people to
believe things that are wrong every time
someone says something that another
person disagrees with they'll go like
you're a grifter you're only saying that
cuz it's a financial incentive as if no
one has ever been incorrect about
anything because they just came to the
wrong conclusion on their own it's like
sometimes people just believe things
that are wrong in fact it's crazy most
of the time people believe things that
are wrong right and you don't have to
believe that the federal government is
paying somebody the reality is we live
in a system where people are not
encouraged to choose virtue when you're
not encouraged to choose virtue you're
going to take the path of lease
resistance as often as possible and that
means falling in line with opinions that
are more popular because it's difficult
to argue for unpopular opinions that's
all it is you don't have to fund anybody
you don't have to run any kind of like
Special Operation to get pop artists
like come on why does someone become
just think about it why does someone
become a pop artist why does someone
become a famous actor because they want
to be liked so as long as the culture
says being liked means having these
opinions then they're going to have
those opinions you don't have to
Blackmail them you don't have to give
them money I I I I I partly disagree a
lot of people who get famous end up not
liking being famous and and they they
try to hide a lot of people who get
famous enjoy being famous it's not
absolute so when I look at someone like
Taylor Swift I don't know so much that
when she was a little kid she she said I
wish I was famous other than she made
music the music got popular now she's
famous there are certainly people who
want nothing but to be famous and what
what do you see they make up fake
garbage on social media for clicks and
likes and that is a lot of people but
even even when it's not a Pursuit Of
Fame and I'm not saying that there are
no famous artists who just believe in
their craft but any kind of performance
art is going to disproportionately
attract people who are attention seeking
and want large crowds to like
them yeah it's like it doesn't have to
be a formal conspiracy anyway people are
just doing what they want to do they're
doing what's best for them you know
there's a much easier scaps conspiracy
that we all already know about and I
will stress it again the feds don't need
to go to any individual Creator and
offer them money or recruit them and
they're secretly CIA it's actually much
easier they send a national security
letter to Facebook
and they say we want your algorithm to
prop up this kind of content yeah that's
it well and I think this and ban this
kind of content this is where thing I
mean this is part of where things
actually start to get really scary I
remember there was something um my dad
said to me when I was in high school
asked him like do you believe in any
conspiracy theories and he said no I
like there the government doesn't need
to cover anything up because the media
will just call you racist or sexist or
homophobic or evil if you point out
things that are actually happening uh
and and try to destroy you that way but
nowadays that's not working like it used
to so they actually do have to interfere
in ways that they didn't before because
they don't control information as
tightly as they used to which is why we
saw uh as Tim alluded to the White House
communicating with Facebook about what
kind of information should be allowed on
that platform
yeah yeah I mean it's this is not
something that that uh um that that
really should be comes any kind of
surprise we've talked about it you know
here all time saying that Taylor Swift
is working for this think I don't know
that I don't think that I don't think
that
anyone or I don't think there are
actually assets like that I think that
the the incentive structures that are
built up uh don't require that and and
and it's the it's it's the same thing
with when it comes to like the Deep
state right like you don't all the Deep
state is is your average people that are
bureaucrats that don't change when the
administration po the but how cool would
it be Taylor Swift was like at January
6th telling people to RI she's down
there going she's like she's no no no I
say how cool would it be if like you
know 30 34 years ago two people are
recruited by the CIA to have a child
which would go on to become a pop star
to influence and control the minds of
the youth and then you've got like
seven-year-old Taylor Swift learning
like you know I don't know Brazilian
jiujitsu and like Krav Maga and then
they're like next up will be your piano
training and they like teach her to sing
that's the whole thing was one big
military s to control the world's
population through music getting into
the uh Donald Trump was a uh Soviet
asset territory I I just like Trump
trump was a Soviet attempt to to raise
someone but they kind of screwed it up
because they had like a lack of you know
proper resources and then Trump went
rogue and became like a world leader in
the other direction I just I I like the
idea that Taylor Swift is like a in the
sense that people usually call
attractive women online feds like she's
like in people's DMS telling them to
commit gun crimes and Stu she's like
what if you drilled another hole there
are no there are no women online
remember that they're all feds Every
Woman online if a woman appears even
remotely attractive on the internet she
is a fed that's fact true that is true
that's the thing that's true about mmor
RPGs right you'll see like a female
character it's just a guy playing a
female character right it's like women
are playing Candy Crush you know what I
mean yeah that's true no that's a fact
that's actually women overwhelmingly
play I love these reports where they're
like women now make up 51% of Gamers and
it's like yeah but you mean like Candy
Crush and Angry Birds they do they do
they do usually that's hilarious like
how many women are playing balers Gate 3
like a small percentage you know what I
mean and you know what women gets so mad
and I'm saying this is a non-gamer okay
but women get so mad at guys for playing
video games you don't hear guys out here
knocking Candy Crush going like I hate
that my girlfriend plays Candy Crush but
the girls are like why is he always
playing Call of Duty like look at the
apps on your own iPhone okay look at the
games you're playing like everyy know
those aren't the games they play they
play games with your head remember
remember when uh it was fresh and fit
they said women don't have hobbies yeah
it's true and they were like why would
he say that but it's like it's because
from a male perspective they don't like
women obviously have hobbies but from a
male perspective they don't so like if I
go to a skate park there's going to be
one woman for every 15 or 20 guys if I
go to the poker room there's going to be
one woman for every 15 or 20 guys when
you when you go to these kinds of things
that guys normally do you you don't see
that many women MH however I don't know
is like getting your hair done in like
fashion a hobby some people argue it is
and so it's like what do women enjoy
doing it's just not the same as what
guys enjoy doing so guys don't see women
around all the time well also so this is
this is my theory and I think this is
actually validated by a lot of the
metrics we have like i q for example but
I think it applies uh across a wide span
of human activities where men either
tend to be like really good at things or
really bad at things things whereas
women tend to be more average so again
we see this with IQ men and women have
the same average IQ but men are more
likely to be smart or dumb whereas women
are more likely to actually just greater
male variability hypothesis exactly and
so I think that's why you see men in a
lot more of these Hobbies uh I think men
are just more likely to become obsessive
over something and get really into it
whereas women are more likely to be
normal yeah yeah to generalize no it's
true that's that's one of the cool
things about being a man is like there
is this um proclivity to just find
something interested in and obsess over
it and I I think that women have that to
a degree for sure but it's it manifests
very differently let's jump to the
important news here Michelle Obama says
she's terrified about potential outcome
of 2024 election she's running so uh the
other day a top strategist for JP Morgan
said that Joe Biden will drop out in
March following super Tuesday I believe
this makes the most sense as of right
now it doesn't mean it's absolute but it
makes sense why many people said Joe
Biden can't drop out it's too late to
hold a primary okay but that's actually
the best thing Democrats could do keep
Joe Biden in the race until it is too
late to hold a primary due to a medical
issue he is forced to bow out and then
because they can't have a primary they
get to appoint someone the DNC does
bypassing the potential for Maran
Williamson RFK Jr or Jen Huger uh
stopping them from winning the
nomination huh in this instance with
this story emerging of Michelle Obama
now popping up and saying she's
concerned about the outcome of
24 I think there's a there's a really
great opportunity right now to put a
wager on Michelle Obama winning the
Democrat nomination or being the nominee
against uh Donald Trump
because well she's terrified about the
potential outcome of 2024 where does
that story go and why is she being asked
exactly because in one month she says my
fear of what's to come in 2024 is so
great I feel like I must do something
about it m a month after that Joe Biden
stumbles and Falls Michelle Obama says
my greatest fear has been realized our
great leader Joe Biden has fallen ill
someone tied his shoes together and he
tripped and now he can't be president
anymore a month later she says I must do
my duty to prevent my greatest fear from
coming to fruition I must run for the
presidency yeah exactly it's
self-sacrificing and every politician
has to have a narrative like this we saw
this with Joe Biden the reason I ran for
president was because of Charlottesville
I saw what happened on television and I
said I need to run I I I saw
Charlottesville happening and said I
need to be the one running this country
it's like all right Joe but that's the
story that he went with and they all try
to have their own little origin story uh
and so this is clearly hers she said I'm
just so nervous about what's happening
Donald Trump he's a criminal they're
going to let this man be president if
she runs I think she wins do you really
think so I I would I would have thought
that um a year or so ago I'm not as
convinced you are black filled man I no
I mean look it she's she's going to go
you think she wins the general election
yeah she she goes and she sits down with
and then like all your soccer moms all
your wine moms are voting for I mean the
only people that won't vote for her are
people that have actual grievance so the
people that are really poed about things
the people that have kids that have
dealt with uh LGBT issues at schools
those people are not going to switch
because uh because she's running but
people that are just people that are
lightly involved in politics that are
middle that are middle class that that
gener
aren't feeling the effects of the
economy or inflation yeah I I I I
disagree for one simple reason these
liberal-minded Suburban moms I don't
think would vote for a black woman I
think they're the reason they believe
Dei stuff is because they're overtly
racist I believe that the only way you
end up with someone preaching about
racism but then actually pushing for
segregation like I saw in Sweden is that
they're deeply racist and they're trying
to prove they're not but in private
they're going to be as racist as they
can be look look at look at all of the
these like these liberal personalities
who say racist things behind closed
doors and they get busted for it or
whatever like I I shouldn't say all
these but like numerous stories of the
past few years and sexist things as well
I'd be willing to bet all of these
liberal you know Democrat wine mobs in
the suburbs would be like oh yeah I'll
vote for Michelle Obama and then
privately like a no way I'm doing that
I'm voting for Donald Trump Tina Fay in
30 in third in 30 Rock say Third Rock
From the Sun in 30 Rock not the alien
one said in the first season I tell my
friends I voted for Barack Obama but I
secretly voted for John
McCain I think a lot of people will
claim they're voting for Michelle Obama
and then they'll be shocked to when it's
actually a narrow race and she doesn't
do as well as people think not to
mention I don't think that the Nostalgia
factor is going to play as well as they
would hope Joe Biden came in he trashed
everything and the issue now is it's not
even necessarily about the person it's
about the party Joe Biden as a Democrat
the Democrats have done so poorly that
Michelle Obama could run and she'll do
better than Biden that's a fact but I
don't know if it's enough to overcome
Trump's success in the polls right now
yeah also I think one massive uh mistake
that the Democrats have made over the
past two years is they've actually
turned parents into a voting Block in a
way that we've never seen before they've
been like well you know I just want to
let you know if you're against porn
being shown to children in schools
you're a big bad far right extremist and
then a bunch of parents went all right
well I guess I'm a big bad far-right
extremist then because I would rather be
that than allow you perverts to groove
my children and uh here we are no you're
both wrong she'll
win you think so oh yeah I I I do I and
and that's not obviously clearly like
I'm not like endorsing Michelle Obama
the like I'm I'm endorsing at least
until the primary I'm like I'm going to
vote for vake in the primary because
he's the guy that's talking about
cutting the government most whoever is
talking about cutting the government
most is who I'm going to vote for I
don't know man I think you're endorsing
Michelle you really seem to want her to
win well anyways uh you can think that
and it's cute but um I like to think
here that Tim is right I would love it I
would love it I would I would like to be
wrong this is not some kind of thing
where I'm like oh man this is what I'm
hoping for I would love to be wrong but
like I said I am blackpilled as hell on
on what the American people want because
I don't see as much as we're seeing push
back against the the people that are are
are complaining about Palestine and
protesting uh and stuff I don't see
enough push back from your normal people
to for me be like oh the general
consensus is not the left leaning
consensus like the Som of life and
everything is just so much there's just
no nothing really pushing them to really
feel like hey I got to do something
about this hey I'm going to stand up and
say something I think I I'm traveling
around even in my own State you know I'm
seeing people that are just being
crushed by by nomics and inflation and
it's the constant talk I've done over 50
town halls and what what you just said I
think Rings true that people are just so
fed up with Democrats and Democratic
Leadership and the lack thereof and how
worse off they are today than they were
under President Trump I hear that a lot
I hope there's enough of them I hope so
too but that is an interesting thought
or comment about how people are uh so
many Democrats are innately racist
themselves and and and we saw that with
you just made me think of U the
immigrants that they flew to Martha's
Vineyard right right exactly and to see
how quickly within what was it 24 hours
they just went ahead and so there was
there was that Yale study several years
ago that found liberals
drop their vocabulary level when
speaking to black people that's right
and conservatives do not and that's it's
really obvious why Democrats well
they've always been racist I mean it's
quite literally their party platform
since the early days but they're like
hey we switched the kind of racism that
we have yeah they're still racist and so
if you have your average liberal who
encounters a black person and then tries
to sound stupid on purpose it's crazy
they're basically saying they think
black people are stupid whereas conser
just talk to them like normal people
because they just think they're normal
people it's really you think a person
who who does that is going to look at
Michelle Obama and think that's the
person they want to lead the country
they may publicly act like they oppose
racism but from their own actions they
show that they actually look down on
minorities and when it comes to the
private decision-making process they're
going to brag to the High Heavens I just
voted for Michelle I actually voted for
Trump but I'm not telling my friends
that because I'll get made fun of
they're going to vote for Trump yeah now
the challenge I think Trump has with a
lot of these women though is that he's
like nasty a lot of these liberal
Democrat women's are like he grosses me
out and so they're going to be put to
the test of whether or not to be more
racist or disgusted and whether or not
like what which will play a bigger role
I got to be honest I think many of these
Democrats are so racist they would say
well I'm disgusted by Trump but they'd
vote for him because that's how racist I
think they are that they wouldn't want
to vote for Michelle and I'm not saying
every single one what we see in the data
from this study is that a a a decent
amount of liberals will lower their
vocabulary level yeah when talking to
black people because they assume black
people are stupid I mean look at the
voter ID thing Amy Horwitz with one of
the greatest political videos ever made
have you seen this one yeah he goes
around asking black people he goes to
Berkeley and he says do you think voter
ID is RAC it's like yeah of course
because black people don't know how to
get the internet and can't get IDs and
then he just goes to Black Neighbors in
New York and he's like do you have an ID
and they're like yeah and he's like do
you have the internet and I love this te
this like 20-year- old guy's like what
do you mean even a 13-year-old kid's got
the internet yeah my favorite though was
when he asks the guy they one of the
Berkeley kids says they don't it's hard
for them to get to the DMV they don't
know where it is and then he asks his
older black guy he's like can I ask you
a question do you know where the DMV is
and he goes yeah it's over there in 26
he's going to go down here make a left
like the guy was asking for directions
it was such a stupid question to ask a
guy he assumed the guy needed help
finding it yeah dude it's it's hilarious
um those people are going to vote for
Michelle yeah right I mean a lot of
these I they might CU it'll make them
feel better about themselves and absolve
themselves if they like
racism hilarious to me is that you know
so for example like as a voice actor
someone who does voices for cartoons
they'll say about me and other voice
actors like you could never do a black
voice but then every time they talk to a
black person they try to do this weird
impression of how black people speak and
this is exactly what that study's
talking about they'll do that they'll
like start using black slang and they'll
as the studies literally show they will
use a dumb down vocabulary it's like
this is insanely insulting and then you
get bent out of shape over like a
comedian doing an impression of a black
person as a joke when you're actually
trying to do it in real life because you
think that's how you should communicate
with another group of people so I want
so there are times when I'm on tour
where I have to go on vocal wrest and
I'm not allowed to talk right so like
people walk in the room and I can't say
anything everyone must hate that it's
super Annoying It's the most annoying
thing in the world but people constantly
come up and they don't know how how to
talk because I can't talk to them and
what the and so what they start doing is
they start whispering or they try to
sign I'm like and it's like I'm the one
that can't talk dummy and I wonder if
that's the same kind of thing they think
that the person they're interacting with
is is unable to so they try if that it's
the same kind of like uh um not like if
they're not thinking about it it's the
same kind of reaction so anyways that's
I just thought it was funny but yeah no
absolutely that's that that's hilarious
yeah have
it's funny how if you like focus on race
and make that into everything you think
about and every only thing you even
matters eventually it becomes the only
thing you think about and the only thing
that even matters
so it can't be any other way like that
if you are constantly thinking about the
point of like there was there's there
was all that talk about critical race
Theory the point of critical race theory
was to awaken a critical racial
Consciousness so that way people would
see things through the lens of a racial
power Dynamic all the time that was the
whole point and so people were all
focused about oh you know they're not
teaching critical race Theory blah blah
blah in schools but what they were
teaching PE what they were teaching kids
was to see everything in a
racialized way and that creates racism
when that's what happens well and not
just and not just in a racialized way
but there's an irony there it's called
critical race Theory but there's only
one race you're to be critical of right
right it's l it's just white people bat
that's all well I mean that's the way
that it pans out here but it what it is
is it's it's just Marxist power power
dynamics so here it's white people but
when it was used in we talked about the
cultural revolution when it was when it
was used in the cultural revolution in
China it was Han Chinese were the
dominant ethnicity and so it was Han
privilege and all the stuff that we're
seeing here all the the the focus on
race it was all already done in China
with different ethnicities that you know
you know your average westner wouldn't
know they wouldn't know the the the
particulars about the ethnic ethnicities
in China but there are a lot of
different ethnicities and the same kind
of power dynamics were used to justify
oppressing the majority that had wealth
and stuff like that so it's not new and
it's it the more we can can reveal these
things to people these these these you
know similarities with some of the most
horrible ideologies in human history the
more you know the better it's going to
be but we have a big job in front of us
yeah I mean and it's no surprise that
somebody tried this right when it comes
to the division that they've stoked
between the races because the fact that
Americans of all different ethnicities
and races got along as well as they did
in the United States is is just
unbelievable it's never been perfect but
for a a good chunk of time over the past
few decades it's pretty much been better
than anywhere in the entire world where
multiple ethnicities have been in one
place including ethnicities that are
really really really similar whereas in
the United States we have ethnic and
racial groups that are are are far more
different than those other ones are
where we see far more conflict and so
it's a miracle that we were able to get
things working as well as we did and so
it's no shock it's no shock that someone
trying to upset the system would come in
and sew those seeds of Discord because
it's a lot easier to destroy something
like that than it is to build something
like that it actually it offers the the
amount of of racial ethnic Harmony that
existed in the United States offers a
tremendous opportunity for evil people
to upset the system because that doesn't
exist anywhere else so it has to be
really easy to tear down yeah and and
the the the way that it's it's you go
about it is by attacking the things that
transcend race which are the the
fundamental principles that are that
make Americans Americans yeah that make
that makes America Americans it is first
of all liberalism right like so all of
these conserving liberalism I I want to
get that like that point home because
you're conserving liberalism I think
people forget that all the time they get
liberal versus conserv you're conserving
liberalism if you want to call yourself
conserv anyways absolutely and the
biggest problem right now that's going
on that we have is that the the
progressives have convinced the
Democrats the liberal Democrats that
they are not liberal they have convinced
them that Progressive policies which are
based on racial you know based on race
or based on sex or based on identity
that are prohibited this specifically
prohibited with the by the Civil Rights
act that these are continuations of the
Civil Rights act when they actually fly
in the face of the Civil Rights Act the
the the people that were marching during
the Civil Rights Act in the 60s they
they were they held signs that said I am
a man the point was they wanted to be
seen as a human being and that and Jim
Crow laws treated them as less than
humans and now the the focus is on I am
black or I am this minority which means
don't see me for my
100% it is 180 from everything the Civil
Rights Movement was focused on the Civil
Rights Movement it was intended to be
liberal because it was intended to treat
people based on their humanity and
everything you hear now is based on race
and identity and that it flies in the
face of liberalism and it is fly it
flies in the face of the fundamental
principles that the United States is
based facts man you know yeah um man
here here dude here here I couldn't say
better myself 100% I think another
reason why that's that happens is
because it's a system of control if they
can have and and and create identity
politics and tribalism the way that they
have you know we got to get this group
against that group it it goes back to
democracy yes much easier to divide
you've got these uh many you know these
groups that are everywhere pitted
against each other you can you can
control them much more effectively yeah
hey great time be talking about this MLK
rest in peace good time to be talk about
this thing is for what day is the actual
holiday is did anyone know off the top
of their head MLK day is what day it's
on the 16th on 16th okay right 15 15th
or 16th yeah yeah Monday anyway good
time to bring it up but yeah I mean the
the the the efforts that are are being
undertaken the point is to tear at the
foundation of the United States we we
talk about uh um you know how they
change the language and how they change
the meaning of words I mentioned this
the other night there's the effort to do
land dedic
the the impulse to do that that's all a
terrible idea because it it gives
credibility to the legitimacy of the
idea that the land is stolen now
throughout history there's been
conquered people throughout history
that's the way you know countries have
been formed and stuff and when you when
you cast the creation of the United
States in the light of illegitimate that
that means that all property in the
United States is now stolen property and
that means that the Fourth Amendment
doesn't protect it it doesn't the
takings Clause doesn't like it's all up
for grabs though once you change the
meaning of words all of the laws that we
have they're the the if the meanings of
the words change all of those laws
they're all they're all nothing more
than than uh a memory because they're
based on ideas you change the words the
definition of the word you change the
idea fundamentally so yeah totally age
again this also ties the idea of like
what Ma did where he'd like be
destabilizing on purpose and then be
that stabilizing force it gives
legitimacy to them again it's all about
legitimizing their claim to power Y
which is you know questionable at best a
lot of times so how could you guys say
something like that on Stolen land you
know sickening no that that argument was
always so ridiculous to me it's like
okay was like how can you have Justice
on Stolen land it's like I guess we
can't have Justice anywhere ever ever
literally forever everything has been
stolen so uh I just left the room yeah I
am now back in the room our flight
tonight was canceled because uh the the
the blizzards in the midwest are are
intense and the roads are basically shut
down so we got this jet waiting for us
and they said they can't do it so uh the
bad news is this means that here's the
plan we're going to try again at 10:
a.m. to fly out but that means I'm G to
have I'm not going to be able to record
my morning show as normal oh man but
there's a solution I just have to wake
up at 6:00 a.m. oh no and record
segments early
and try and just record maybe you know
because normally I record about an hour
but it's over several hours of of doing
research and pulling up news stories and
reading a lot so they may be what I
would describe as lesser segments like
more cultural stories where I'm
commenting on like a Tik Tok video or
something and then just get like three
or four segments cranked out at like 6:
a.m. so we can make a 10 a.m. flight
which means we will we will keep the
uncensored members only show tonight a
little bit shorter than we normally
would in that uh maybe just a half an
hour tonight instead of 50 45 50 minutes
okay so I can get to bed and wake up
early and then we got to fly to De Mo
Iowa at 10:00 a.m. tomorrow morning oh
this is so brutal hey I heard de Mo's
great this time of year I mean they got
a blizzard and uh but uh I think I'm
really excited for this event that we're
doing this uh V town hall is very very
important for for everything that's
going on so uh we're going to have to
figure out how to make it work and uh I
can sleep when I'm
dead yeah the plan is going to be we'll
uh you know that's what I've been saying
with this campaign I can sleep in 6
months you know right I'll just wait you
got to get the grind keep going wake up
get it done anyway now that we're back
let's go to Super Chat so if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends head over to
timcast.net to help cover the costs it
looks like we may have a sponsor won't
won't cover the full cost but we'll help
alleviate some of the stress that means
if you like the work we're doing and you
like the idea of hosting a counter town
hall to CNN's fake debate then support
our work go to
timcast.net I mean we'd be able to buy
Billboards in every single major city we
we could be able to buy all the ad space
on CNN I mean we're talking about 40,000
people giving 10 bucks a month that'd be
amazing so with your support we can
continue the work we do and be
substantially more successful that being
said uh smash that like button let's
read what y'all got to say Clint Torres
is back he says howdy people he has of
course won the first place position by
the uh being the first Super Chat Jose
Alfredo Diaz says first sorry sir you
are
second ooh
straight Common Sense Asian says so
happy to see you on my favorite newscast
you better nail it your wife next
appointment depends on it
haha I know exactly who that is shout
out to Hung he's uh the great the great
happy uh Happy design nail salon in in
my city and where my wife goes
constantly and so he is a huge huge fan
uh that's that's
great all right I'm just I'm just
checking on the flight year cuz uh yeah
oh this going to be so brutal things
change fast too I know but we're doing
big stuff this year it's going to be a
big year and we got we got a bunch of
big shows planned uh we've got uh uh don
Jor is going to be coming on the show
this week while we're in De Moine
because you know everybody's trying to
get their last minute pitches in for the
caucus and it's going to be really
really great all right here we go Jacob
parody says did anybody see JP Morgan's
10 Shockers 20124 well the one I can
mention is that Joe Biden drops out
there were a couple others that I didn't
really care that much about I don't know
if you guys read the full list but I'm
sure there's something in there that's
probably more interesting or or or could
be
interesting right all
right Western body says second vote
early vote uh second vote early vote
often yes Raymond g Stanley Jr says
simple question need only simple answers
there's no need for all the meaningless
hoopla that makes you sound not
confident with your
answer that's right yeah today uh in the
arguments uh uh in in the Trump Appeal
on immunity I'm really I'm really
frustrated
with Trump's lawyer trying to like the
judge said to the lawyer if the
president committed an assassination and
ordered SEAL Team Six to do it you're
saying that they could not be prosecuted
if they weren't
impeached the answer to that is correct
I'm saying that they cannot be impeached
instead that the the lawyer is like no
it's qualified qualified yes I mean like
if he's impeached and the judge is like
let me try again
now it is annoying the way that J are
asking questions but if you're making a
point it's just as simple no the
president cannot be criminally charged
or indicted unless he has been impeached
and convicted next question that's it's
that
simple all right the silent says P first
no sir you were you're very very off
sorry he says watch chainsaw man Peak
anime I've I've heard of it I watch it
I'm actually just re-watching Yu Haku
show oh you like coost detective well of
course but uh Netflix made a live
version which is just so awful I didn't
I'm not even going to watch it it's only
five episodes and it tries to condense
like elements of the whole show into one
it's really funny cuz he like for no
reason goes to get trained by Gen Kai
and then he's there for literally 10
minutes out of the show but then he's
like no when she dies and it's just like
what it just doesn't work sorry your
live action yakit does not work but the
actual show itself was awesome yeah true
all right where we
at what do we have Zachary McCoy says
why will people say there's no good
candidates with this Biden Trump
election again but not even consider
vake we are doomed I I seriously it's
it's fascinating to me that V is not
Trump in terms of uh character and
cander he's America first but you have
these people like I'm going to vote for
Nikki Haley I wouldn't vote for Trump
and it's like well then why would you
just vote for Vi America First PR the
economy real business experience mhm I I
I I think it's cuz I like
him you're turning everybody off I yeah
you know yeah po poor V you know he
tells the truth and then the media lies
about him but that's what that's what
they do that's what they do with
everybody exactly if Vape went up on
stage and said January 6 was an inside
job he goes up on stage and he goes it's
looking more like January 6 is an inside
job and I want to fund the
military-industrial complex to blow up
foreign countries and CNN would be like
he's completely right about everything
he's correct January 6 was an inside job
uh more money for the military military
industrial complex but the moment he
says we shouldn't be engaging in Foreign
Wars and providing all this foreign
funding they're like he's crazy it's the
worst
yep all right Matthew Rose says Tim Jews
and tunnels sounds like some World War
iish that's actually a really great
Point yeah if it is true that the reason
they built the tunnel and I heard this
is because the city locked down places
of worship illegally and
unconstitutionally and they were
fighting for their right to worship they
were in the right to do so and they did
so non-violently I can respect that now
I do have concerns about the structural
Integrity of the building so you know
digging tunnels underground can be very
dangerous and also I just want to say um
to to all my Catholics on behalf of all
the other Catholics we are slacking like
they have tunnels where where are our
catacombs where are the catacombs under
the large cities that Catholics live in
well Steven bortle says here is some
money some spoon money Tim I hear they
keep going missing for some reason hey
Sheamus hey how's it going uh you know
so this morning mhm we have these little
mugs that are um we got from REI they're
uh they're they're like a thermos but
they're mugs yeah what about right and
uh oh I have one and Allison has one
yeah yeah those are nice and Allison
uses hers because when she pours her
coffee in it you can put a lid on it and
it's not quite a thermos but it's a mug
that keeps things warm well hers was
gone huh this morning and weird she was
wondering where it went and she noticed
that this strange thing keeps happening
where mugs from our kitchen keep
appearing in the studio building that is
weird as if someone is taking our mugs
who's staying at our house and then
walking out with them walking to the
studio while drinking the coffee and
then leaving it in the other kitchen
that's really weird it is very strange
yeah I wonder why that's happening it
must be a ghost um I think you probably
should get paranormal investigators or
check the security camera footage on the
property for sure the only the only
explanation is that a ghost is makinging
coffee and then carrying the cups into
the studio and uh perhaps the ghost is
in the room right now with us yeah he's
only been here for like the last 2 or 3
days or 3 days a little scary because
why would the ghost get here when I got
here I know I must ghost must be
following you do you really think so per
yes perhaps uh it's a ghost
Sheamus dud I don't even want to think
about that it's freaking me out that's
freaking me out um in other words
Sheamus is stealing our mugs what hold
on that's where you were going with that
are you that's rid hold on a second we
don't actually have any evidence that
any of this happened Alice I would never
look out my window and see Sheamus
drinking coffee and walking up there
listen you I you guys know me I would
never do that I would never do something
like that you know me the funny thing
about you guys know me the funny thing
about the spoons thing was that it was
like three spons it was like three
spoons and I didn't even take that and
Sheamus is the one who turned it into
this big meme because he wanted
attention for him no that never even
happened I didn't take anything you guys
know me you know I wouldn't do that
actually happened is like Allison
noticed that some spoons were not in the
kitchen she like oh there's some spoons
they're not like do you think Sheamus
has them downstairs yeah and then
Sheamus comes up and Al was like oh did
you bring spoons and I was like oh I'll
grab them and then he walks up with like
three and puts them in the sink and then
Sheamus goes there's an Irish man living
under my house stealing my spoons why
would I say that why would I say that
when I never took your spoons that's so
offensive towards towards me and my
Irish man living under my house stealing
my spoons Sheamus made that up and then
when we all laughed at it Sheamus denied
it ever do that anyway it's not true Tim
said I made a secret tunnel under his
house to steal spoons I'm like what is
this stairs what talking he's like I
heard people speaking Irish under my
apartment I have no basement I don't
know where this is I saw an Irishman
coming out of the ground in front of my
house I smack the camera yeah and then
run Zach aasi says be safe in your
travels tonight most of our roads here
in Iowa are listed as mostly covered uh
to travel not advised as I'm getting
ready for work well the crew said they
will not fly and uh so we're going to
fly first thing in the morning and I'm
just groaning like it's so expensive we
just like we can't cancel it and you
know so uh we're talking with the crew
and figuring things out but I'm going to
wake up at 6:00 in the morning and try
and record as much as I can to have some
segments up and uh then you know
just Mitch the engineer says Tim can I
get a birthday shout out also does
anyone know chicken sounds also does
anyone if the ray EPS judge oversaw any
of the rest of the j6 trials maybe have
grounds for an appeal I don't know if
you can appeal based on determinations
of different judges like that but uh
Happy Birthday Mitch the engineer yeah
happy birthday all right where are we
at let's see uh fat hsky says looks like
Trump has the perfect defense with Ray
EPS would you
agree no because Trump does not want to
argue he in any way incited anybody to
go into the capital so if he says I
incited people but look you can't
criminally charge me then he's just
admitting that what they want him to
admit you know yeah I think just to the
contrary right I mean he he said many
times peacefully go up to the capital I
I don't think there's any evidence he's
never been convicted of conspiracy of of
insurrection charged convicted nothing
and yet he's going through all of this
right now yep that's where I I love VI I
got to say he is he's phenomenal I mean
I went out uh when I get endorsed by
Charlie Kirk I was able to meet him
brilliant brilliant guy yeah oh yeah
absolutely brilliant guy Donald Trump I
have endorsed because I can see what's
going on the Deep State what we talked
about here um I mean there's so much
going on where he has exhibited that
strength to stand up and push back uh
that is exactly what we need right now
the needs to stay in this race because
they're doing everything they can to
remove Trump from it and if something
happens in the next few months where
Donald Trump is removed from the primary
we are going to be very grateful that we
have the as an option in the primary now
I don't know what that means in terms of
voting for Trump but this is going to
get really wild and we are looking at
1860 levels of like election okay
electioneering and and election out of
History four candidates in the election
in 1860 we could be looking at four
candidates this time around let's say
Donald Trump is booted from the from the
ballot so he announces I'm still running
you can't stop me he runs as an
independent the Republican primary is
defaulted through this process to Nikki
Haley then RFK Jr runs independent and
Joe Biden or Michelle Obama you have
four candidates and what happens Trump
easily wins that four-way race no
question and and the only way Trump does
win if it is is if it is split three
ways like that Trump's base is massive
it's like 40% of the GOP they will write
Trump in he will lose 60% of that vote
but it will be split among RFK Jr in a
tiny degree Nikki Haley will not get as
much as people think Michelle Obama may
get a bunch but I think Trump wins the
plurality in that regard and that will
be a strong justification Democrats will
use for either some kind of secession or
Rebellion because they'll say Donald
Trump is the president but only won 29%
of the
vote we'll see though Victor Gordon says
Casper should work on creamers to pair
with the coffees and I just got my first
order today love it yo I I I I'm sorry
man like Appalachia kns the cas Brew uh
blend that we made like we got the
samples we tried it out it was my idea I
said here's what I think would be really
good we'll try it it is the best coffee
I've ever had no question it's a dark
roast it's a blend that we came up with
and uh it's just man once you drink
Appalachia nights I'm sorry man it'll
ruin coffee for you it's so good y
seriously that good as long as you brw
it right but I'm really excited for the
Alex Stein's Prime Time grind uh two
times caffeine that we just put out a
lot of people are talking about how they
like certain uh double caffeine Blends
and now they have an option from uh cast
Brew Ian's blend is going to be a low
acidity blend so uh we're looking at
coffees with low acidity to create the
the perfect coffee that is low acidity
and uh that's going to be Ian's graphine
dream yes and that and that actually
should be coming out in a few weeks
we're really excited for uh the bags
look so cool I mean Jessica such an
amazing artist the graphine style bag
and everything and we're look we're
really excited for
this Ian says let's hope the judges come
to the conclusion presidents can be
charged then every conservative da can
file against Joe and demand he be
arrested yeah but come on you know
they're not gonna just too lazy they're
going to be like oh geez what do I do
you're you're your um yeah your your
point presumes yeah I did cut out there
your point presumes that anyone in
Republican politics at that level is
useful I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm going to
put you here on the spot good sir
running for the Senate yeah should uh
does the Second Amendment protect the
right of children to keep in bare
arms it protect the right of children to
keep in be
arms well I would think it it is it is
applicable to every US citizen so yes
you are correct uh particularly in Most
states they actually have codified the
laws as it pertains to Children keeping
and bearing arms that means uh this
requires parental supervision or some
kind of Permitting process but it is
protected so we saw this with the
Written House case where uh the argument
was he's not old enough to keep in bear
arms ah but the provision actually says
you can be under the age of majority and
keep in bear arms for specific reasons
and if you actually go back in time you
can see where this applies very easily a
13-year-old kid would be given a rifled
musket to go out on the hunt with the
father and so in in most circumstances
children can bear arms so long as
they're accompanied by their parents and
that's makes sense the next question put
you on the spot does the Second
Amendment protect the right of private
uh private persons to keep and bear
nuclear weapons weapons of mass
destruction and
warships I'm going to say no the answer
is
yes raon Boeing locked Martin are
private entities and priv private
persons as per the US uh uh tax law and
code and they are the ones who build our
warships and our missiles and our
weapons so yes private persons as per US
law do keep and bear weapons of war and
mass destruction so uh typically private
persons to include corporations yes but
it also does mean individuals
individuals because the only reason it's
a corporation is because the amount of
wealth required to do such a thing and
you're going to want to limit your
liability you know like if you're if
you're a private person you're not going
to be like I as my sole proprietorship
I'm going to build a Hellfire missile
because you'll be very much responsible
personally and all your assets but um
you know I've asked a lot of uh
conservative politicians and liberal
politicians they always say no and I'm
just like who do you think's make making
our bombs it's private corporations yes
you can fill out ffls and say you're
building a nuke so it's it's it's always
been the case that the Second Amendment
protected the right of uh citizens own
cannons warships Etc I love I love that
factoid because it's actually quite
simple it sounds more complicated and
trickier than it is if someone thinks it
sounds unreasonable you just say like
locked Martin and Ron are private
entities as per US law they're not
they're not the government regulated and
permited and all that stuff of course of
course but they have missiles you know
so there you go it's always been the
case huh privateers and Corsair Etc all
right let's read some more Paul tascal
says Tim I own a private jet company
Vault
Aviation I'll donate $2,500 to a charity
of your choice for the opportunity to
quote your next trip uh PS be prepared
to pay a $5,000 plus de ice fee on your
Iowa flight today oh don't you know it
don't I Know It uh absolutely so the the
the cost of this trip is very very
expensive it is absurdly expensive plus
we've got uh the dead head the storage
of the plane while we're in Iowa cuz got
to fly us back and uh cuz we're flying
back Monday night it's brutal
and then of course we have de icing fees
now we may Dodge de icing because um
we're flying tomorrow and it's going to
be sunny and cold so um we likely will
still have I think when we're leaving we
may be okay depending B based on the
weather but uh you know we'll see yeah
probably going to have some kind of di
syn Fey I think it's probable but we may
we may Dodge it but uh Vault Aviation
let me uh let me write that down right
now and uh we'll take a note of
this I'm writing it
down yeah you know I hope hope we're
able to make it it'd be really really
cool if we can if not you know we'll
make the best of it we'll still have
some awesome shows yeah so uh it's it's
it's brutally expensive I mean
uh it's it's it's not been the I'll just
say this we started uh flying uh private
because it's the only way we can do some
of these shows and make them happen and
I'm not some you know cringe climate
change bleeding heart I I don't mind
flying private and don't complain about
it uh but the price have been going up
substantially and it's crazy you know
it's like we we're we're getting a
private jet for for one trip where we're
doing a Big Show and it can seat eight
or nine people and the cost is usually
like with if you're flying your crew out
there it's it's basically twice the cost
of first class would we give every
employee first class no but it's like oh
man the amount of time you save if we're
going to fly crew out and I put them on
a commercial jet and the Jet gets
delayed or the baggage gets damaged we
can't set up the show we're screwed so
it's basically like welcome to the PJ
ladies and gentlemen because we're all
going to get there on time we're going
to set the show up we're going to build
the studio out it's a lot of work we're
not going to get any sleep it's going to
be a little bit more expensive than
usual but we're going to have a great
show and it's going to matter that's
right that's what it's all
about all right TRD says didn't AOC
confirm or elude to uh elude to Capital
Personnel aiding protesters in regards
to j6 to Alex Stein play the video well
we don't have the video pulled up but
you are correct she did AOC said why
were police helping them yeah well it's
an inside job according to AOC according
to CN according to Joe Scarboro so I
think it's a it's case
closed all right monk in training says
I'm Jewish was this tunnel in Brooklyn
the hus is there that Rabbi was a
dynamic leader and polyglot the idea
that he's the Messiah is fringe in the
US but popular in the hidic sect
everywhere else on Earth h really
interesting that's
interesting but he died what 30 years
ago uh yeah
I94 Kea says today Poland president
harbored two politicians who were
sentenced for two years for S by SC for
corruption they refused to leave the
presidential Palace after 8 hours of
standoff the police finally went in and
executed the arrest very interesting
also uh Ecuador is in Civil War I think
yep yep crazy a bunch of armed gunmen
stormed a TV station dude guys I mean we
should have pulled it up I guess let's
talk about this in the members only yeah
watch these videos about what happens
when social order breaks down you're
like I can't believe a bunch of armed
gunmen in t-shirts stormed into a
television broadcast pointing guns at
people it's that quick humans can do
human stuff man the human human rules
matter a little it's all
confidence the rabbi act says Sheamus I
was literally taught how to read HEB in
Hebrew school Rabbi was completely
unconcerned if we knew what we were
reading just how fast and good sounding
it was I can't even read it now wow that
means he was he was more concerned than
the average public school teacher is
with ensuring students can read in
English yeah yeah that's crazy but
that's interesting because that was one
thing I always admired one thing that
always made me sad is that Catholics
stopped teaching their kids to to read
and speak in Latin I think that was
that's a massive loss I wish I was
taught that as a child so I always
thought it was cool that that Hebrews
still did that it's uh interesting to
learn though that many of them don't
care because that's one of the three
sacred languages right um Latin Hebrew
and Greek Steel Toad says preserve them
when an extremely smart individual turns
their intellect to activism they focus
that intellect to that desired outcome
positive or nefarious they will focus on
that objective you know I think there's
an important thing uh to mention when it
comes to intelligence when we talk about
race and intelligence there's this like
liberal offense that's taken by it that
people could have different intelligence
uh averages based on their race I think
that's stupid because it presupposes
that intelligence is better than other
characteristics without actually
addressing any other characteristics of
any other race the the Assumption there
is that intelligence is the most prized
attribute of humanity and I don't think
that's correct I certainly think it's
fairly obvious when uh I went to
Thailand and it was on Chinese New Year
and when I went to this big Market you
know what I saw over the heads of every
person because be me being 510 510 and a
half mind you uh the average height in
Thailand was lower it was like 5'6 5'7
so when I'm standing there I'm actually
taller than everybody I'm like wow this
is this is really interesting yes this
racial group has a slight difference in
uh uh in their in their in their builds
I went to Sweden and I was short even
the women are six feet tall in Sweden me
too but uh there was this discussion
from Sam Harris I think it was Sam
Harris and I think it was um and other
IDW people talking about that it's not
as Extreme as as the media might make it
seem when making these arguments but
there's likely a a genetic component in
uh intelligence as well as every other
attribute but that is not to say that it
determines the capabilities of an entire
racial group like if if you if you take
the if you take if you argue that Korean
have high IQs but then you raise this
kid in a civil war with no food yeah
they're going to be developmentally
stunted if you if you bring anyone from
any other country and give them the the
internet tutors wealth and access
they're going to be one of the smartest
people on the planet I don't think it
plays that big role but you know fun
stuff I think we should recognize that
there are other attributes human beings
have besides intelligence that have
value all right let's see where we
at hypebot says Phil is 100% correct
about Michelle Obama the average US
voter is basically mindless name
recognition is the number one thing
number two is do I hate this person a
far third place is actual policy well I
agree with that but I just think
liberals and especially like these
liberal Suburban Democrat moms are just
really racist I'm I'm rooting for Tim to
be right by the way well let's say this
are they racist uh well I think they are
but I don't think they I don't think
they're aware it's not even a question
of course they're like I I won't say all
of them but people on the left I mean
one of the the platforms at this point
is you have to hate white people so yes
black people um if we want to count like
soft big of low expectations is racism
absolutely and that just means racist
with a guilty conscience yes so so they
have a guilty conscience that doesn't
mean they're actually going to trust
someone to run the country right the
mentality of these liberal women will
probably be something like you know I
really support the efforts of these poor
under prived privileged people but the
right decision for my family will be
Donald Trump MH because they're racist y
they would they would discount a
person's kency based on race I think
that's I think that's fairly uh I think
that's a good a good
bet oh let's go Thomas tjg says has Phil
ever used vocal rest as an excuse to
avoid conversations with
dags uh on tour literally every single
tour every single tour since
2007 absolutely not around here though
we we when we were we were at like
tpusa they've got music blasting and and
everyone's trying to talk to me and I'm
just like I can't talk cuz I would have
to yell and I'm going on stage later on
to do a show and so then I shut up and
then they just keep talking at me and
asking me questions and I'm just nodding
I'm like just not saying things I'm like
guys like maybe if the music was all all
the way low and I could talk in a normal
voice but I'm not going to yell cuz
seriously talking to someone backstage
with music blasting super loud for one
hour and then I'm talking like this yeah
not interested
yep that could be a great excuse by way
you know you encounter some Progressive
you're like hey I just can't maybe
that's what they want anyway probably
yeah Brandon Hawkins says Tim next time
you make a pot of coffee put a pinch of
salt in the ground so you can thank me
later I'll give it a try my Aunt T told
me that but I I would always put too
much and it would taste salty but when
she did it it was it was really good it
made it very smooth really really if
it's bitter coffee like at a gas station
you put a little bit of salt in there
that always makes it not as bitter it's
usually it's like overcooked or
overheated but it really has to be like
a tiny bit though I tried to portions as
small as possible and after rooting like
two pots I was like I'm not I'm hanging
out the casino and the lady walks by and
she's like drinks and I'm like I will
have a coffee with 10 cream and no
sugar that's way you got to do it man
you got dirty looks too I'm yeah and one
guy was like man this guy wants a splash
of coffee in his cream yeah exactly and
I said look you want to drink some mil
if they had heavy whipping cream I'd ask
for coffee with heavy cream but you know
they don't personally as a cream purist
I think that half and half is is an
affront it's offensive
okay you want coffee with cream you get
cream I was in London and I was having
breakfast at a hotel and I said uh I'll
have coffee with cream and they went um
we'll see what we can do and I was like
okay they bring you clouded cream they
no they brought heavy whipping cream oh
nice okay and uh cuz they don't have
half and half no they they they use milk
and I was just like but milk is not
fatty mhm like when you want half and
half it's cuz you want you want to add
fat to your coffee exactly I just say
look if you're going to do like two
creams just do one heavy cream like yeah
it's it's absurd that you're adding half
and half when you can just do a little
bit of heavy cream use real cream right
you know what's going on man endorsed
endorsed it's very it's very very
delicious it is very
delicious and uh let's go Zack Balden
says the live show isn't showing up on
YouTube I just search for it that's how
it's been since Christmas yeah we know
they they suppress us and it's only
because fans actively seek the show out
that we resist their their efforts it is
what it is but tomorrow's Town Hall will
be live on YouTube and U Monday's show
with a live audience will also be live
on YouTube so you don't want to miss it
we're having the town hall with f it's
going to be a podcast Town Hall Hybrid
we'll figure that out we're going to
discuss uh with our team exactly how we
can run it so it'll be a very like open
conversation talking about a bunch of
ideas VI will have a majority of the
floor but it's still going to be podcast
hybrid style so it's not going to be you
know like an interviewer saying tell me
about this and then letting him talk
it's it'll be a bit of a back and forth
and we'll try and bring in the audience
as much as we can and then uh the 15th
is caucus day and the caucus begins
right on the time we normally go live
8:00 P.M and then uh we will be live to
track the caucus and talk news and uh
we'll have a rotating panel of guests
it'll be a lot of fun we're going to
have a Don Jr is scheduled to be joining
us this week so he can he can discuss uh
obviously his father's campaign and uh
we're big fans of trump I know Phil said
he's gonna be voting for Vi uh we'll see
I'm of course leaning towards Trump but
we'll see how it plays out there's a lot
to be said for what's going to happen
smash that like button subscribe to the
channel share the show with your friends
head over to
timcast.net
we do if tomorrow uh I won the Mega
Millions $165 million the drawing was uh
probably just now if I want $165 million
I swear to each and every one of you
100% of that money would be invested
invested into winning the culture war in
every conceivable way no questions asked
so when you become a member at tim.com
we are not here to build infinity pools
or by Ferraris we are here to build a
skate show to build culture the the new
studio that we have it's beautiful and
it's amazing but it's all part of a
mission in building culture and
inspiring young people and uh raising a
generation of people who believe in the
Republic who believe in the Constitution
and uh meritocracy and individual
responsibility thank you for your
support you can follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me personally
at timcast mayor Stags do you want to
shout anything out yeah I just want to
give a shout out to my family uh my wife
Felicia and my two great children
Brennan and Brin they're uh they're
fantastic they're they're why I'm doing
this you know they really are it's uh
we've got to save this country we have
to absolutely right on you got a Twitter
account anyone can follow yeah uh Trent
stag.com is the is the website stgs and
mayor Stags on X um and social media on
x correct right on thanks for hanging
out Sheamus my name is Sheamus run a
YouTube channel called Freedom Tunes we
make animated cartoons we're going to be
releasing one this Thursday U I'm happy
about it I think a lot of our videos
lately have been really fun so if you
guys want to go over there check it out
subscribe I'm also going to be at the
Town Hall event this week really amped
for that so thank you all for Watching
God bless you have a wonderful day and
and I'll just say if you want to support
me go to Freedom tunes.com become a
member you'll get extra cartoons that
the public doesn't have only you have
and uh you'll have a lot of behind the
scenes content as well we have like over
50 cartoons there this point well over
that that are just exclusive for the
website so Freedom tunes.com become a
member I love you all my name is uh
philon I'm Phil that remains on X I'm
Phil that remains official on Instagram
the band is All That Remains you can
follow us on oh let's see Spotify Apple
music Pandora Amazon music you know the
internet and I am surge.com uh it is not
a website that is my moniker it is
spelled do o t m this is a great show
thank you very much for coming I
appreciate it um and uh I am a Utah man
I am again one more time we have a new
cat that we caught and we uh decided to
name it Sheamus M and the funniest thing
ever is that for the first time Sheamus
is back in town to meet the cat and he's
in the kitchen and little Sheamus walks
up and Sheamus goes hey Sheamus I am not
calling him that it's weird the first
time I called him that it felt weird and
it's it's really difficult to have a a
cat named after you running around it's
like look when you guys named a a
chicken after Luke I was like that makes
sense right then then they name this cat
after me and I'm like well you know it
is what it is and it's all but the
problem is it actually causes trouble
because when people say like oh like
Sheamus is crapping in the corner people
think it's the cat ha all right
everybody we'll see you all over at
timcast.net